[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis schönen guten abend viel
fußball geht zum sport mit norbert
lehmann
unseren nachrichten themen
zwischen stolz und angst zum
ukrainischen
unabhängigkeitstag hat präsident
seelands geht den kampfeswillen seines
landes bekräftigt
die usa sagen neue militärhilfen zu
raumtemperatur unter weniger beleuchtung
das kabinett verkündet neue
energiesparmaßnahmen für öffentliche
gebäude und kommunen wie düster werden
herbst und winter
und mehr fachpersonal und
sprachförderung 4 milliarden euro extra
will der bund in die frühkindliche
bildung investieren und so die qualität
der kitas stärken aber es hagelt kritik
am morgen des 24 februar also heute vor
genau sechs monaten geschieht was viele
trotz aller warnungen nicht für möglich
gehalten hatten russland greift die
ukraine an die usa kündigten heute an
die ukraine mit weiterer waffen hilfe zu
unterstützen
im wert von drei milliarden euro
nach schätzungen der vereinten nationen
wurden bislang fast 6000 zivilistinnen
und zivilisten getötet über elf
millionen menschen sind geflüchtet der
halbjahres tag fällt zusammen mit dem
ukrainischen nationalfeiertag vor 31
jahren hatte sich das land von der
sowjetunion losgelöst aus der ukraine
hannah hebestreit in kiel fällt die
traditionelle parade zum ukrainischen
unabhängigkeitstag aus das kriegsgerät
wird gebraucht und so präsentieren sie
stattdessen erbeutete russische panzer
die wollte präsident putin hier gerne
auf eine siegesfeier rollen lassen nach
drei tagen krieg doch auch nach sechs
monaten ist er davon weit entfernt
den haben wir ukrainer beschlossen den
russen zu helfen damit ihr traum in
erfüllung geht allerdings sind die
panzer ausgebrannt oder von unseren
streitkräften auf andere weise zerstört
worden auch in diesem krieg geht es um
die macht der bilder sollen auch den
menschen die seit monate lang
verteidigen gut machen ich hatte hier
fünf kameraden in meinem alter heute
sind noch zwei am leben ich kann das gar
nicht glauben ich kann nicht beschreiben
wie es mir damit geht
und so wie denken sie heute auch der
nach regierungsangaben 9000 ukrainischen
soldaten die im kampf gegen solche
waffen gefallen sind oder eher weiter
bestehenden gefahr einer atomaren
katastrophe in der ukraine hat präsident
selensky am abend vor dem un
sicherheitsrat gewandt
die internationale atomenergiebehörde
muss so schnell wie möglich die ständige
kontrolle des atomkraftwerks borussia
übernehmen russland muss sich
zurückziehen und mit der nuklearen
erpressung aufhören
es ist ein stiller unabhängigkeitstag
mit großer bedeutung für die linke
und jetzt ist als einer hebestreit aus
kiew zugeschaltet hannah der ukrainische
präsident hat heute gesagt er werde den
krieg erst für beendet betrachten wenn
sein land gesiegt habe was steckt hinter
seiner aussage
greift eine stimmung in der bevölkerung
auf die wir schon oft selbst in unseren
interviews gehört habe angesichts von
9000 offiziell zugegebenen gefangenen
ukrainische soldaten kann er sich
überhaupt keine nachgiebigkeit gegenüber
russland leisten das wäre so etwas wie
politischer selbstmord die toten werden
nicht als opfer gesehen das auf gar
keinen fall hätte umsonst sein dürfen
militärisch kommt die ukraine nicht so
richtig voran es gibt zwar erfolgreicher
nadelstiche auf der krim und auch
schläge gegenüber den nachschublinien
der russischen truppen im süden der
ukraine
aber all das kann dazu beigetragen haben
dass man inzwischen doch der meinung ist
man könne die inversion nicht nur
stoppen sondern die invasoren auch
zurückdrängen da gerne hebestreit in der
ukraine
und gehen wir weiter nach moskau zu
unserem korrespondenten axel sturm axel
wie sehr stehen die menschen in russland
noch hinter putin
es ist unheimlich schwierig ein exaktes
gefühl für die gesellschaftliche
atmosphäre für die gesellschaftliche
stimmung zu kriegen denn wie sie ja
wissen alle proteste sind verboten
drakonische strafen werden und das hält
auch weiter an erst heute wurde ein
weiterer vermutlich der letzte
oppositionspolitiker verhaftet der
ehemalige bürgermeister von
jekaterinburg glaubt man den offiziellen
zahlen die veröffentlicht werden also
von den meinungsforschungsinstituten ist
die zustimmung zu putin nach wie vor
sehr groß liegt irgendwo zwischen
77 und 80 prozent
dankeschön axel sturm nach moskau
der krieg in der ukraine bewegt viele
menschen in deutschland die solidarität
und die bereitschaft zu spenden sind
groß und so kann die diakonie
katastrophenhilfe durch die spenden
eines ihrer bislang grössten
hilfsprogramme finanzieren allein im
ersten halbjahr 20 22 kamen 63 millionen
euro zusammen wir haben uns ein paar
projekte angeschaut für die die gelder
verwendet werden und man leskovar hat
mehr
zweimal im monat kommen die lkw im
auftrag der diakonie in die ukraine
geliefert werden lebensmittel
hygieneartikel für die bewohner der
umkämpften gebiete im osten seit
kriegsbeginn konnte die
katastrophenhilfe über 63 millionen euro
spenden sammeln im vergleich zum vorjahr
eine imposante summe die
spendenbereitschaft war im letzten jahr
sehr hoch mit blick auf die flut in
westdeutschland und das ergebnis was wir
jetzt haben diese 63 millionen ist fast
das ergebnis was wir im gesamten letzten
jahr zusammen erreicht haben verwendet
werden die spenden auch in den
nachbarländern der ukraine in polen etwa
für geldkarten besonders bedürftige
geflüchtete erhalten pro monat 150 euro
um das nötigste kaufen zu können
diese hilfe ist wirklich wichtig wir
sind seit juli hier und haben nur noch
zehn euro
meine kleine tochter muss lebenslang
medikamente einnehmen sie braucht
spezielle nahrung für ihr alter ist sie
sehr klein
hierzulande werden rund 250 projekte
unterstützt begegnungsstätten wie der
blau-gelbe treffpunkt im
niedersächsischen neustadt geflüchtete
können sich hier austauschen dafür gab
es 60.000 euro das meiste davon brauchen
wir für personalkosten und die
restlichen das restliche viertel circa
15.000 euro brauchen wir für die
täglichen bedarf diakonie
katastrophenhilfe hofft dass die
spendenbereitschaft nicht nachlässt
schon jetzt laufen die planungen für den
winter um die menschen in den umkämpften
gebieten weiter versorgen zu können
auch in den nächsten monaten werden also
sehr viele menschen unterstützung
benötigen das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe zu dem auch die
diakonie gehört bittet weiter um spenden
und zwar auf das konto de 65 104 106 100
104 106 100 stichwort zdf nothilfe
ukraine
am ende ihrer kanadareise kam ganzer
stolz und wirtschaftsminister habe zum
wohl wichtigsten programmpunkt sie
besiegelten gestern abend ein
wasserstoff abkommen deutschland und
kanada vereinbaren darin eine
langfristige zusammenarbeit
kanada soll ab 20 25 grünen wasserstoff
liefern produziert mit windenergie
dazu wollen beide länder in den nächsten
jahren ihre häfen ausbauen
energie sparen das ist das oberste gebot
um von russischem gas unabhängig zu
werden jeder beitrag zählt so
wirtschaftsminister habe heute schon
nächste woche gilt für öffentliche
gebäude in der regel höchsttemperatur 19
grad das hat das bundeskabinett
beschlossen die vorgaben betreffen auch
die kommunen sie müssen weniger strom
und gas verbrauchen wo immer es geht
isabel de la vega die wiesbadener
stadtbibliothek im winter wird es hier
beim lesen künftig etwas frischer sein
die temperatur soll mit beginn der
heizperiode auf 19 grad gesenkt werden
das hallenbad in der nähe ihre bahnen
werden die schwimmer dann bei 24 grad
ziehen müssen zwei grad weniger als
sonst
das ist nicht schön und was macht man
nicht gerne aber ich glaube in der
konsequenz aller unserer anstrengungen
energie zu sparen ist es erforderlich
die kommunen müssen energiesparen nach
der neuen verordnung soll die temperatur
in allen öffentlichen gebäuden künftig
bei 19 grad liegen zum händewaschen muss
dort dann auch kaltes wasser reichen
außerdem soll die straßenbeleuchtung
reduziert und leuchtreklamen nachts
abgeschaltet werden nicht alle finden
das gut wir haben schon gespart was das
zeug hält und man wird über
energiesparmaßnahmen die lücken nicht
auffüllen können sondern nur noch ersatz
energie bei den wiesbadenern aber
überwiegt das verständnis für die
maßnahmen dass man kann auch bei 20 grad
schwimmen das muss nicht 21 22 man kann
auch bei 20 grad zu hause in der in der
wohnung sitzen man muss da nicht im t
shirt rumlaufen sonst ist es irgendwann
gefährlich wenn ich draußen im dunkeln
geht oder wenn ich alleine
kinder oder jugendliche alleine
auslaufen und die dunkle ist auch nicht
richtig meine ich finde es eigentlich
tatsächlich sogar ein armutszeugnis dass
wir in deutschland darüber diskutieren
wie warm unsere häuser geheizt werden
werden gleichzeitig menschen in europa
sich überlegen müssen ob sie überhaupt
sein haus zurückkehren können drinnen
wird der winter in diesem jahr kühler
und draußen nachts etwas dunkler sein
kommen wir jetzt zu corona denn das
kabinett hat heute neue regeln
beschlossen sie sollen im herbst die
befürchtete neue welle in schach halten
zustimmen muss noch der bundestag ab
oktober soll die fsp zwei masken
pflichten fernzügen festgeschrieben
werden und auch in flugzeugen gelten
ebenso in krankenhäusern und
pflegeeinrichtungen
dort braucht es vor zutritt einen
negativen test und je nach infektions
lage können die bundesländer obergrenzen
für veranstaltung in innenräumen oder
auch die masken pflicht vorschreiben
mehr von christian hübscher zwei
minister die in der korona politik
unterschiedlicher nicht decken könnten
stellen heute den regierungs fahrplan
für herbst und winter vor die wichtigste
botschaft lockt downs und
schulschließungen soll es nicht mehr
geben in anbetracht der tatsache dass
wir uns vorbereiten müssen haben wir
hier den bundesländern ein paket an die
hand gegeben sehr maßvoller regelung die
auch wenn wir uns in europa umschauen
sich maßvoll verhalten steigen die
infektionszahlen dürfen die länder ab
oktober wieder masken pflicht verhängen
für den öffentlichen nahverkehr für
schulen ab der fünften klasse sowie in
gastronomie kultur und sport ausnahmen
für getestete frisch kämpfte und
genesene sind hier möglich eigene regeln
in jedem bundesland karl lauterbach der
vor einer neuen welle bereits wand will
das verhindern
wir werden natürlich auch im vorfeld
also wenn der herbst kommt mit den
ländern darüber reden und versuchen mit
den ländern etwas hinzubekommen dass es
möglichst viel einheitlichkeit gibt
somit ich rechne nicht mit einem
flickenteppich und die länder aber
fordern schon jetzt klare kriterien ab
wann welche regeln gelten sollen es
würde einfach sinn machen zu sagen
abwasser monitoren incidents
hospitalisierung since it ends welche
gewichtung haben die da würde ich mir
vom bund schon noch gerne antworten
wünschen bundesweit soll ab oktober die
masken und testpflicht in krankenhäusern
und pflegeeinrichtungen gelten
verschärft wird die regel für fernzüge
und flugzeuge hier braucht es künftig
zwingend eine ffp zwei maske dazu passen
nicht die bilder vom vizekanzler und
journalisten im regierungsflieger ohne
maske aber alle pcr getestet eine
sonderregel der luftwaffe sagt das
verteidigungsministerium umstritten aber
auch in der koalition ja es ist ebenso
es gibt eigene regeln für die luftwaffe
und für die flugbereitschaft und die
sind hier zur zum einsatz gekommen
politisch würde ich uns empfehlen als
bundesregierung dass wir überall die
gleichen regeln anwenden die auch sonst
gelten der regierungsvorschlag für den
corona herbst wandert nun in den
bundestag änderungen dort nicht
ausgeschlossen
in deutschland kümmern wir uns stark um
die kleinen fische bei der
finanzkriminalität aber die dicken
fische die schwimmen uns davon so sagt
es finanzminister
und kündigt an den kampf gegen
geldwäsche verbessern zu wollen es
schlägt dazu eine komplett neue
bundesbehörde vor inklusive eines
kriminal finanzamtes vor allem einige
bundesländer reagierten verhalten ihr
argument es gäbe schon ausreichende
kompetenzen in der steuerverwaltung
die lösung liege nicht in einer neuen
mammut behörde hieß es etwa aus bayern
es wird viel erwartet von einer modernen
kita neben der betreuung klar auch
soziale integration und sprachförderung
für die kinder außerdem jede menge
flexibilität und berufstätige eltern zu
unterstützen
fest steht eine solche kita kann es
eines nicht sein billig der bund will
nun in den nächsten beiden jahren vier
milliarden euro zuschießen denn das
sogenannte gute kita gesetz der früheren
koalition läuft aus viel zu wenig geld
sahen kritiker vor allem bei
gleichzeitig ein spezielles programm zum
deutsch lernen gestrichen werden soll
heike slansky mit den details
mit leidenschaft bringt erzieherin einer
app die seit fast elf jahren den
jüngsten die deutsche sprache näher
dafür gab es eine zusätzliche halbe
stelle in ihrer kita finanziert vom bund
doch damit soll nun schluss sein ich war
wirklich sprachlos weil wir einfach
gesehen in welchem erfolg dieses
programm hat und gerade jetzt in der
situation wo wir wirklich viele viele
neue kinder auch aus ganz europa noch
möglich die frühkindliche
sprachförderung knapp 8000 fachkräfte
deutschlandweit die nun nicht wissen wie
es weitergeht kita-träger enttäuscht das
hat uns sehr gewundert weil wir davon
ausgegangen wird es wird verlängert es
stand so auch im koalitionsvertrag und
ohne diskussion mit verbänden oder
trägern kam die streichung ins gespräch
es hagelt kritik die
bundesfamilienministerin
appellierte heute an länder und kommunen
ihr neues kita qualitäts gesetz zu
nutzen um die sprachförderung
fortzusetzen auch wenn das ursprüngliche
modell projekt ausläuft thema
sprachförderung ist nicht das einzige
qualitätskriterium aber ich finde wir
sind alle miteinander gut beraten das
doch hin zu bekommen weil es ebenso
wichtig ist doch dass geld fehlt hinten
und vorne mit knapp vier milliarden ist
der bund künftig dabei obwohl kitas
eigentlich ländersache sind in der summe
jedoch ist das weniger als vorher das
geht jetzt entweder zu lasten der kita
gebühren zulasten der eltern oder es
geht zu lasten der qualität eine
qualitätsoffensive mit weniger geld paus
gesetz geht nun in den bundestag
zwei jahre gab es die wegen corona nur
um online format nun öffnet die
videospielmesse gamescom wieder ganz
analog ihre pforten in köln präsentieren
rund 1100 aussteller aus 53 ländern ihre
neuheiten
einige große namen der branche fehlen
aber wegen der panne und des ukraine
krieges stellen sie ihre produkte erst
kommendes jahr vor ein trend neue
konsolen sollen nach herstellerangaben
nicht mehr strom verbrauchen als
vorherige
zu einer zug panne mitten in der
reisezeit geschehen gestern im
eurotunnel zwischen frankreich und
england tief unter mehr hunderte
passagiere mussten fast fünf stunden
lang ausharren nachdem der autozug aus
calais liegen geblieben war durch eine
wartungs tunnel gelangen sie zu einer
ersatz bahn die brachte sie zum ziel
terminal im englischen folkestone
mittlerweile läuft der betrieb wieder
normal
jetzt kommt ihr zum fußball norbert und
zu den letzten qualifikationsspielen der
champions league und haben gestern abend
millionen menschen in der ukraine
natürlich kiew die daumen gedrückt
dynamo hatte schon das quali hinspiel
gegen benfica lissabon verloren und
musste auch im rückspiel eine klare
niederlage einstecken
benficas neuer trainer roger schmidt
geht mit einem 2 0-vorsprung in dieses
rückspiel sechs tage zuvor hatte sein
team leicht und locker im polnischen
lodz gegen kiew gewonnen auch die
gestrige partie äußerst einseitig 27
minute ort am ende die führung für den
portugiesischen rekordmeister kiew
beeindruckt und mit fehlern si roger
will auf seinen torwart zurückspielen
übersieht dabei aber den flinken radfahr
20 vierzigste minute und weil es gerade
so schön läuft der ziel benfica noch vor
der pause durch näheres den 13 0
endstand der fast mühelosen einzug in
die gruppenphase der champions league
ein erster achtungserfolg des ehemaligen
leverkusener trainers roger schmidt
ja und morgen dann die auslosung der
champions league gruppen erstmals mit
fünf deutschen verein bei uns ab 18 uhr
zu sehen im livestream auf sport studio
de ja und in der konferenz league
qualifikation da geht es morgen abend
für köln ums ganze der fc hat ja das
hinspiel gegen fair war daheim mit 1 2
verloren dennoch äußerte sich kölns
trainer steffen baumgart heute
zuversichtlich dass sein team
weiterkommt
das dfb pokalspiel zwischen
regionalligist otten sind und
titelverteidiger leipzig am dienstag
wird nicht in dessau stattfinden der
grund unbekannte haben den rasen im
dessauer starken und mit einer
chemikalie schwer beschädigt der platz
ist unbespielbar
der dfb und beide vereine haben heute
beschlossen die partie in leipzig
auszutragen
zur deutschlandtour da gab es heute als
prolog in weimar erstmals ein
einzelzeitfahren
ja und das gewann der italiener filippo
ghana auf der ultrakurzen 2,6 kilometer
strecke bester deutscher
vorjahres-gesamtsieger nils polit auf
rang drei
und morgen dann die erste von vier
etappen von weimar nach weinigen
und jetzt haben wir noch die lottozahlen
für sie die gewinnzahlen lauten 7 15 26
34 40 49 superzahl ist die sechs weitere
gewinnzahl finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und zdf text auf seite 5 157
das sommerwetter geht auch morgen weiter
im osten gibt es selten schauer und
gewitter sonst bleibt es sonnig und heiß
mehr gleich von katja horne fahren das
heute-journal können sie um 21 45 sehen
mit marietta slomka im interview bundes
außenministerin barrack auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend von gleich zwei seiten macht
sich die gewitter luft zu uns auf zum
einen mir aus südosteuropa da gab es
heute auch wieder unwetter und zum
anderen auch aus dem südwesten sie sehen
dass hier an diesen gewitterwolken über
südostspanien angetrieben wurden diese
gewitter von dem tief bei den britischen
inseln so entwickelten sich bei uns am
nachmittag einige quellwolken im westen
im osten waren die wolken dichter und
bleiben ist auch in der nacht die
quellwolken im westen dagegen lösen sich
auf und es gibt eine tropische nacht
zumindest am niederrhein da sinken die
temperaturen nicht unter 20 grad
deutlich kühler wird die nacht am
alpenrand mit angenehm frischen 9 grad
die höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 24 grad an der ostsee und 35
grad am niederrhein im westen scheint
dazu die sonne strahlend richtung osten
sind die wolken etwas dichter und
vielleicht könnte es dann am nachmittag
zum beispiel in der lausitz oder auch in
ostbayern mal für einen kleinen
regenschauern kurzes gewitter erreichen
die gewitter nehmen aber zu freitag und
samstag sind vielleicht sogar unwetter
dabei also gewitter die mit hagel
platzregen und sturmböen verbunden sind
spätestens am sonntag aber beruhigt sich
die lage von gästen einen schönen abend
noch